zdf heute live schönen guten abend wir
blicken nach trier wo ein mann am
nachmittag durch die fußgängerzone
gefahren ist und mit seinem wagen
mehrere menschen erfasst hat das motiv
ist noch unklar in wenigen minuten wird
die polizei dazu eine pressekonferenz
geben
wir sehen das im rathaus von trier im
moment noch niemand auf dem podium sitzt
die kollegen warten noch darauf dass
unter anderem der rheinland-pfälzische
innenminister roger lewentz und der ubi
der stadt trier der oberbürgermeister
vor die presse treten wird unter anderem
sobald es losgeht gehen wir natürlich
direkt live nach trier ins rathaus von
mindestens zwei toten spricht die
polizei
darunter offenbar auch ein kleinkind
offenbar wurden auch mindestens 15
menschen verletzt
trier heute nachmittag nach angaben von
augenzeugen fährt der mann fast einen
kilometer lang durch die fußgängerzone
ganz in der nähe von der porta nigra das
wahrzeichen von trier
ein großaufgebot von polizei und
rettungskräften ist im einsatz
augenzeugen berichten von schrecklichen
bildern menschen seien durch die luft
geflogen gegenstände auch die situation
habe ausgesehen wie im krieg in der
innenstadt berichten augenzeugen
offenbar ist der mann wahllos durch die
fußgängerzone gefahren und habe dabei
menschen angefahren vier minuten hat das
nach angaben der polizei gedauert bis
der mann von der polizei gestoppt und
festgenommen werden konnte er saß
offenbar allein im wagen und ist ein 51
jahre alter deutscher aus dem kreis
trier saarburg der trierer
oberbürgermeister spricht von einem
mordfall die rheinland pfälzische
ministerpräsident in malu dreyer hat
sich noch heute nachmittag auf den weg
nach trier gemacht das ist für sie nicht
irgendeine stadt sondern ihre
heimatstadt sie wohnt ihr selbst
zusammen mit ihr
mann der lange jahre selbst
oberbürgermeister von trier war und sie
hat sich am späten nachmittag zu den
vorfällen dort geäußert ja es ist ein
sehr schlimmer tag für uns hier in trier
aber für das ganze land rheinland pfalz
auch es ist eine bedrückende stimmung
hier in dieser stadt und es ist einfach
nur schrecklich wenn man an die
angehörigen der opfer denkt die
wirklicher von klar ich auf nichts
sozusagen aus dem leben gerissen worden
sind aufgrund dieser schrecklichen tat
und viele verletzte auch man kann nur
hoffen und beten dass sie ja gesund
werden und dass alles gut überstehen es
ist ein schlimmer tag für uns alle und
unsere ganzen gedanken sind bei den
angehörigen unter den toten ist auch ein
baby und das ist auch das ist auch zu
spüren in der ganzen stadt wenn
wundert's das ist zwar ein grausamer
gedanke dass ein kind was grade ja das
licht der welt erblickt hat dann durch
so eine schreckliche tat verstirbt und
man will gar nicht daran denken was die
eltern jetzt miterleben müssen die
ganzen angehörigen das ist einfach ganz
ganz grausam und ich kann nur sagen das
entsetzen ist tief das mitgefühl ist es
auch wir alle denken und die angehörigen
und ich kann auch sagen auch unseren
nachbarn egal ob er premier aus
luxemburg ist ob der außenminister ist
ob die bundeskanzlerin ist sie alle
haben sich bei mir gemeldet einfach auch
um ihre anteilnahme auszudrücken
tja und dieses tiefe mitgefühl das
teilen auch die user kämen brockmann
schreibt über facebook mein tiefstes
beileid für alle betroffenen und deren
angehörigen das ist einfach nur
schrecklich und utah an war schreibt
ebenfalls über facebook mein
aufrichtiges beileid den angehörigen und
der familie es tut mir sehr leid
rest in peace unsere reporterin nina
niebergall ist für uns in trier am
tatort nina wie ist die lage dort im
moment ja genau christina wir stehen
jetzt hier direkt an der porta nigra
sozusagen die einkaufsstraße wo die tat
heute mittag passiert ist im rücken die
lage ist hier tatsächlich sehr ruhig
also hier ist jetzt noch polizei vor ort
bis vor wenigen minuten war das
technisch
berg noch vor ort die sind jetzt gerade
abgefahren ansonsten sind hier
tatsächlich nur medienvertreter und
einige sehr wenige passanten die polizei
hat die einkaufsstraße noch komplett
abgesperrt ansonsten hier sind
tatsächlich alle geschäfte geschlossen
die restaurants sind sowieso geschlossen
wegen wir haben musste ich an dieser
stelle genau gestorben und fast schon
gespenstisch kurz unterbrechen nina für
den moment herzlichen dank wir gehen
direkt zum oberbürgermeister der stadt
trier zu wolfram leibe ins rathaus nach
trier wo die pressekonferenz jetzt
eigentlich beginnt und das tut sie auch
genau jetzt
ja ich frage jetzt einfach mal ja
ja liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
sie sehen gerade noch wie die herren auf
dem podium vorgestellt werden wolfram
bleibe der oberbürgermeister der stadt
trier und auch der innenminister des
landes rheinland pfalz roger lewentz
beide haben sich heute schon tief
erschüttert gezeigt über das was dort
passiert ist und während die kollegen
gerade noch über die abläufe informiert
werden
nutzen wir die zeit und noch mal kurz
zusammenzufassen was passiert ist ein
mann ist heute in der fußgängerzone in
trier in mehrere menschen hinein
gefahren offenbar wahllos hat den
menschen getötet und drücken sie das
lendringsen zu dieser pressekonferenz
ich sage es aber ganz deutlich ich habe
mich sehr gefreut sie alle heute hier
nicht sehen zu dürfen
ich glaube es ist der schwärzeste tag
der stadt trier nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg
wir alle sehen diese bilder sie als
journalisten sehen diese bilder im
fernsehen und ich glaube gedenken immer
sowas passiert nur an anderen orten nein
es passiert bei uns und anderswo
und wir wollen uns nicht wegducken wir
wollen uns jetzt der aufarbeitung
stellen
ich bin zutiefst erschüttert die ganze
stadt ist erschüttert und ich habe
tiefstes mitgefühl mit den angehörigen
der innenminister wird ihnen noch gleich
die zahlen geben es ist schrecklich wie
viele tote es ist schrecklich wie viele
schwerstverletzte und verletzte menschen
ja
ich kann nicht verstehen wie jemand auf
die idee kommt mit einem suv durch die
innenstadt zu fahren und menschen zu
töten menschen töten baby neun monate
bis zu einer dame die 72 jahre alt ist
was haben diese menschen getan
sie wollten den die stadt sie wollten
einkaufen gehen und jetzt sind sie tot
die solidarität die ich bekomme ich habe
mich sehr gefreut dass angehörige vom
breitscheidplatz bei mir angerufen haben
und den minister wird auch gleich noch
erklären dass wir auch aus berlin
wirklich zuspruch bekommen haben
ich möchte mich an der stelle bei allen
einsatzkräften hier in trier bedanken es
waren fast 700 einsatzkräfte unterwegs
und es hat gut funktioniert es ist nicht
selbstverständlich dass nach wenigen
minuten der täter verhaftet werden
konnte und damit die große große sorge
vieler menschen in trier was passiert
noch eben beseitigt werden kann
die menschen in trier trauern und wir
werden morgen an der porta nigra die
seit 1800 jahren in dieser stadt steht
ein trauerort einrichten damit die
menschen an diesem ort ja in sich gehen
können und ihre solidarität zeigen wir
werden in trier in trier saarburg
trauerbeflaggung machen und der
innenminister hat mir schon gesagt in
ganz rheinland pfalz die menschen
brauchen solidarität und hier ist auch
noch mal da aufruf an alle trainerinnen
und trainer
lassen sie uns zusammen diese schwierige
situation durchstehen und helfen wir den
menschen die in den krankenhäusern
liegen
schwerstverletzt und verletzt es sind
aber auch ganz viele menschen
traumatisiert sie müssen sich vorstellen
in der innenstadt waren heute mehrere
hundert menschen unterwegs und vor deren
augen wird gemordet wie verarbeitet man
das und deshalb herzlichen dank für ihre
solidarität und ich gebe an der stelle
ab an herrn lebens den innenminister des
landes rheinland pfalz der heute
zusammen mit der ministerpräsidentin
direkt nach trier gefahren ist sehr
geehrter herr lebens das sind ihre
mikrofone
ja meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
das ist ein schrecklicher tag für das
land rheinland pfalz für unseren
mitbürgern mitbürger ich glaube das ist
nach der schrecklichen rammstein
katastrophe es weiter mal dass menschen
in dem maße mitfühlen mitgenommen sind
weil es gewalt ereignis gegeben hat dass
jedem und jeder nahe geht und ich bin
seit 14 jahren im innenministerium und
habe so eine situation auch noch nicht
miterleben müssen
der op hat es gesagt erlaube mir
ministerpräsidentin ich hier sind
unmittelbar dann hier an den ort des
geschehens gekommen und wir waren
natürlich bei den rettungskräften bei
den einsatzkräften am dom an der porta
nigra
wir haben uns auch aus der distanz die
situation des geschehens angeschaut und
man muss ja allein an den abgelaufenen
ereignissen sehen zickzacklinien bahn
gezielt menschen zu suchen um ihnen leid
zuzufügen
und das ist ein ganz ganz schlimme maße
geschehen
wir haben vier todesopfer wir haben vier
schwerstverletzte
wir haben fünf weitere erheblich
verletzte menschen und sechs
leichtverletzte und hinzu kommen mehr
als 2000 menschen die traumatisiert sind
also das ist ein ganz ganz schreckliches
ereignis jagen frau bundeskanzlerin frau
merkel hat unmittelbar die
ministerpräsidentin angerufen
bundesinnenminister was seehofer hat mit
mir telefoniert und ich glaube dieses
ereignis erschüttert ganz deutschland
und ich will auch an der stelle ein
herzliches wort des dankes sagen das
sind so viele menschen sofort als helfer
dagestanden menschen die unmittelbar an
der an den stellen des jeweiligen
unglücks gewesen sind als passanten dann
unglaublich schnell die einsatzkräfte
sie hatten rund 300 einsatzkräfte der
rettungsdienste der feuerwehren thw zum
einsatz und über 450 polizeibeamte
austria aus dem bereich des gesamten
polizeipräsidium zur hand wir haben sehr
schnell die besten kräfte
zusammengezogen war das galt trier zu
sichern war zu diesem zeitpunkt
natürlich nicht klar war wie sich eine
solche lage entwickeln kann
die bundespolizei war mit dabei und die
wasserschutzpolizei und ich finde dass
es bei all diesen schrecklichen
umständen ein gutes signal dass nach der
alarmierung bei der polizei binnen vier
minuten der täter festgenommen werden
konnte und damit sicherheit gewährt
werden konnte dafür sage ich auch noch
mal ein herzliches dankeschön
wir haben eine situation dass wir davon
ausgehen müssen ich nehme an die
staatsanwaltschaft sagt dass er gleich
mal etwas genauer das was ein täter aus
der region ist mit einem deutschen
hintergrund und wir sehen jetzt schon im
netz dass es auch dort wieder
spekulationen gilt gibt die hier keiner
bestätigen wird ganz im gegenteil wir
haben klar es wird von dem verdächtigen
deswegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren die schon einmal sagen die
ministerpräsidentin die landesregierung
ist
als zuständiger innenminister wir alle
der opferbeauftragte herr platzeck wir
alle versuchen natürlich an der seite
der menschen zu stehen mit ihnen zu
fühlen mit ihnen zu leiten die ihre
liebsten verloren haben oder deren
angehörige verletzt oder gar schwer
verletzt sind
natürlich werden wir auch in ganz
rheinland pfalz die fahnen auf halbmast
setzen weil ich glaube das ganze land
ist mitgenommen und die weiteren punkte
soweit man konkretisieren kann bitte ich
die staatsanwaltschaft und die polizei
dann auszuführen ich glaube sie sind
ja meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
die polizei trier ist heute um 13 uhr 47
mit dem ersten notruf und danach einer
ganzen reihe von weiteren notrufen
darüber in kenntnis gesetzt worden dass
offensichtlich ein pkw durch die
fußgängerzone in trier fährt und dort
menschen an und überfährt
nach dem gegenwärtigen stand der
ermittlungen ergibt sich für uns
folgendes bild wie sie auf der grafik
sehen können begannen nach unseren
erkenntnissen die fahrt an einem an
diesem roten punkt im bereich der
konstantinstraße in trier
von dort ist das fahrzeug in die
fußgängerzone eingebogen in richtung
norden in die brot straße und von dort
weiter über das zentrum trias über den
hauptmarkt in diese million straße und
weiter in richtung porta nigra um dann
den bereich der fußgängerzone wieder zu
verlassen und nach rechts in die
christophstraße in richtung hauptbahnhof
ab zu biegen dort haben sofort
alarmierte kräfte von uns das fahrzeug
stehend angetroffen und den
fahrzeugführer der sich allein im
fahrzeug befand überwältigt und
festgenommen
soweit nach unserer erkenntnis lage der
äußere geschehensablauf im laufe der
fahrt in der fußgängerzone kam es zu der
reihe von schwerverletzten und
leichtverletzten und leider auch zu nach
unseren erkenntnissen bisher vier
tödlich verletzten personen bei dem
täter
handelt es sich um einen 1969 in trier
geborenen deutschen staatsbürger der in
der region wohnhaft ist der nach unseren
aktuellsten erkenntnissen die letzten
tage zumindest nicht in einer wohnung
sondern in seinem fahrzeug verbracht hat
ansonsten laufen die ermittlungen noch
und sind in vollem gange und in soweit
würde ich dann an den herrn leitenden
oberstaatsanwalt übergeben
schön und das meine damen und herren
auch ich möchte kurz das vorwort sagen
ich bin seit 26 jahren staatsanwalt die
meiste zeit davon habe ich bei der
staatsanwaltschaft trier verpackt aber
eine derart sinnlose tat in unserer
region mit so vielen toten ist mir noch
nicht untergekommen untergekommen
auch mir bleibt ein stück weit der atem
stehen wenn ich an dieses szenario denke
zum stand der ermittlungen kann
naturgemäß zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch
nicht allzu viel sagen die tat ist
gerade passiert der beschuldigte ist
festgenommen worden unmittelbar nach der
tat er befindet sich zurzeit im
polizeigewahrsam
beim beschuldigten handelt es sich um
einen 51 jahre alten mann der in der
region wohnt und auch in trier geboren
ist also aus der region stammt die
ermitteln gegen ihn wegen des dringenden
tatverdacht des mordes und vier fällen
sowie der gefährlichen körperverletzung
in einer ganzen reihe weiterer fälle
gehen davon aus dass er bei dem angriff
in der innenstadt mit dem fahrzeug
heimtückisch handelte und das fahrzeug
als waffe benutzt und deshalb mit
gemeingefährlichen mitteln handelte das
erfüllt den tatbestand des mordes
er ist soweit wir bislang wissen nicht
vorbestraft bislang das motiv der tat
ist bislang noch völlig unklar
der geschädigte wird derzeit momentan
vernommen er macht auch angaben habe ich
gehört aber die vernehmung ist noch am
laufen so dass man sich zu einer
etwaigen motivlage nicht äußern kann
wir haben aber keine anhaltspunkte dafür
dass irgendwie ein terroristisches motiv
ein politisches motiv oder ein
religiöses motiv eine rolle gespielt
haben könnte es gibt anhaltspunkte dafür
dass möglicherweise dass es
möglicherweise ein psychiatrisches
krankheitsbild gibt der beschuldigte ist
kurz begutachtet worden durch einen arzt
des gesundheitsamts aber auch da müssen
die weiteren ermittlungen
die genauen hintergründe beleuchten es
wird im laufe des ermittlungsverfahrens
mit sicherheit ein psychiatrisches
sachverständigen gutachten in auftrag
gegeben werden dass sich zur frage
schuldfähigkeit einschränkung der
schuldfähigkeit usw äußern muss der an
der beschuldigte war auch alkoholisiert
er hatte zuvor nicht unerhebliche mengen
alkohol genossen seien seine atem
halbblut es seine
atemalkoholkonzentration betrug 1,4
promille
die muss eine blutprobe entnommen worden
wie viel alkohol konsumiert hatte wird
erst dann durch die blutprobe genau
festgestellt werden können
er wird morgen einem ermittlungsrichter
beim amtsgericht trier vorgeführt werden
es ist bislang noch nicht klar ob gegen
ihn haftbefehl beantragt werden wird
oder möglicherweise im hinblick auf
dieses möglicherweise psychiatrisches
krankheitsbild das eine rolle gespielt
hat einen antrag auf einstweilige
unterbringung in einem geschlossenen
psychiatrischen krankenhaus erfolgen
wird das werden wir erst nach abschluss
der vernehmung wahrscheinlich erst im
laufe des morgigen vormittags
entscheiden so viel von der
staatsanwaltschaft
sehr geehrte damen und herren dieser
einsatz stellt uns natürlich vor eine
ganz besondere herausforderung
die ersten kräfte waren sehr sehr
schnell vor ort gewesen und da kann man
nur ein lob an der stelle an die trierer
bevölkerung aussprechen
die waren also das war kein patient
keine person die betroffen war auf der
straße gelegen die schon von anwohnern
vorbeikommen personen versorgt wurde
die kräfte von uns waren unmittelbar an
einsatzstelle eingetroffen
natürlich ist das eine enorme psychische
belastung solch ein einsatz wie die
eingesetzten kräfte und das ist auch
besonders herauszuheben
die bilder vom so eine einsatzstelle
müssen nicht einsatzkräfte mit nach
hause nehmen und sie werden sich auch
noch längere zeit mit auseinandersetzen
müssen und das ist auch eine aufgabe von
uns für die zukunft
insgesamt waren 300 einsatzkräfte von
uns in den einsatz eingebunden in der
erst phase kommen wir direkt
rettungsmittel und löschfahrzeuge die
qualitativ auch besetzt waren von
notfallsanitäter in den einsatzraum
entsenden wodurch sehr sehr schnell eine
eins-zu-eins-betreuung umgesetzt werden
konnte eins zu eins betreuung heißt
jeder patient war unmittelbar relativ
zügig durch entsprechende rettungs
rauschmittels rettungsdienstpersonal mit
dem entsprechenden krieg mit versorgt
worden was auch dazu geführt hat dass
wir also sehr viele leute jetzt da
retten konnten diese einsatzlagen das
ganze system beginnen bei den
ersthelfern über diese qualitativ
kollektiven rettungsdienst ist hin zu
den krankenhäusern hat aus unserer sicht
super funktioniert die zwei großen
kliniken in trier haben sofort umgesetzt
auf notfall betrieb es gab keinerlei
probleme irgendwo patienten in
krankenhäusern abzugeben
also muss ich ein sehr starkes buch
aussprechen einmal in die eingesetzten
kräfte
die da vor ort sehr guten job geleistet
haben aber auch die krankenhäuser in
trier die sofort sich dieser sache
gestellt haben und wir sofort
unmittelbar alle patienten in die
kliniken transportieren konnten damit
halt die versorgung durchgehend
sichergestellt war
wie gesagt es waren über circa 300
einsatzkräfte aus dem nichtpolizeilichen
gefahrenabwehr im einsatz gewesen
das geht dann von den kräften der
feuerwehr über die kräfte der
hilfsorganisation aus stadt und dem
landkreis trier saarburg die institution
worden sind über kräftige landesweit
zusammengezogen wurden sind aus größte
fachkompetenzen dann eine einsatzstelle
mit abbilden zu können
und wenn alle diese eingesetzten kräfte
jetzt ein sehr sehr großer dank von
meiner seite
vielen dank
[Musik]
ja so weit also die pressekonferenz aus
dem rathaus in trier ich fasse noch mal
kurz zusammen
es hat opfer gegeben im alter zwischen
neun monaten und 72 jahren vier menschen
wurden getötet bei dem was heute in
trier passiert ist 700 einsatzkräfte
waren vor ort ein mann ein 51 jahre
alter deutscher der in trier geboren ist
und dort in der nähe gelebt hat ist
offenbar gezielt im zickzackkurs durch
die fußgängerzone von trier gefahren
vier todesopfer gibt es zu beklagen vier
schwerstverletzte weitere verletzte und
natürlich dutzende menschen die
traumatisiert sind weil sie all dieses
mit ansehen mussten zum täter hatte
ermittelte staatsanwalt ermittelnde
staatsanwalt gerade folgendes geäußert
es wird gegen ihn vermittelt wegen
versuchten mordes in vier fällen weil
davon auszugehen ist dass er
heimtückisch und vorsätzlich das auto
als mordwaffe benutzt hat der täter ist
nicht vorbestraft es gibt hinweise auf
ein psychiatrisches krankheitsbild das
sind alles erste eindrücke nach ersten
vernehmungen die im moment noch laufen
und was man auch sagen kann ist dass der
täter alkoholisiert war und 1,4 promille
im blut hatte als der atem
getestet wurde das also ist im moment
der stand dessen was wir wissen und
damit gehen wir zu nina niebergall nach
trier die für uns am tatort ist nina
kannst du noch einmal zusammenfassen wie
die lage da vor ort im moment ist ja
gerne also ich stehe direkt an der
simeonstraße das ist diese
einkaufsstraße wo der mann eben heute
mit seinem suv durch gefahren ist und
dabei wie wir jetzt wissen vier menschen
getötet hat wir stehen hier direkt an
der porta nigra
das war sozusagen der endpunkt seiner
fahrt und hier ist tatsächlich immer
noch die die ganze einkaufsstraße und
auch die straßen drumherum das ist alles
noch abgesperrt die polizei ist noch vor
ort man merkt jetzt allerdings ganz
langsam entspannt sich die situation
immer mehr polizeifahrzeuge verlassen
hier wieder den tatort und auch das
technische hilfswerk ist schon wieder
abgefahren
nina ich versuche gerade mal ein
bisschen ordnung in den chat zu bringen
der offenbar irgendwie auf dem weg dazu
ist aus dem ruder zu laufen weil dort
leute zunehmend nur hass verbreiten
wofür wir diese sendung weiß gott nicht
machen
wir haben gerade mal gefragt ob es
fragen an dich gibt vielleicht kommt da
noch was das wäre natürlich sehr schön
einstweilen kann ich die zeit nutzen um
auch positive kommentare vorzulesen die
gekommen sind
luca renner schreibt zum beispiel über
facebook mein beileid an alle
betroffenen und großes danke an alle
einsatzkräfte und ärztinnen und justin
schreibt auch über youtube gute arbeit
der eingesetzten beamten rettungskräfte
und sonstige helfer dickes dickes
dankeschön
das muss man ja auch mal sagen nina du
hast auch mit ein paar leuten dort
sprechen können mit fußgängern die dann
noch unterwegs waren und sind obwohl
natürlich auch für trier der teil
lockdown gilt obwohl wenige menschen auf
der straße sind
was haben diese menschen die erzählt ja
du sagst es also es sind tatsächlich
sehr wenige menschen hier unterwegs ich
konnte aber eben mit ein paar menschen
sprechen beispielsweise mit einer frau
die hier heute mittag tatsächlich schon
vor ort war und die jetzt vorhin noch
mal hier vorbei kam und ich habe sie
gefragt wie sie die stimmung hier
beurteilt und sie hatte sofort tränen in
den augen
wir haben jetzt schon häufiger von
entsetzen von schock gesprochen und das
hab ich da tatsächlich bei dieser frau
auch sofort erleben können sie sagte das
hätte sie sein können sie macht hier in
ihrer erledigung gleichzeitig ist
natürlich auch noch weihnachtszeit man
sieht es
hinter mir geschmeckt erst seit wenigen
tagen und sie meinte es sei ganz
fürchterlich ihr brach irgendwann die
stimme weg und wie gesagt einfach
geschockt und entsetzt
auch wahrscheinlich weil man in trier
dachte das kann überall passieren aber
eben nicht hier bei uns vor der eigenen
haustür
wir haben auch mit einer augenzeugen
sprechen können über skype leonel
ellinor hertel entschuldigung sie 17
jahre alt und mit einverständnis ihrer
eltern hat sie uns heute nachmittag noch
erzählt wie sie das erlebt hat heute als
augenzeugen
das schauen wir uns gemeinsam an das ist
schwer zu beschreiben ich war sehr
geschockt ich konnte das irgendwie gar
nicht realisieren dass das jetzt
wirklich so passiert ist also für mich
noch gar nicht wirklich wahrheit ja ich
habe mir das dann irgendwie angeguckt
und als dann immer mehr verletzte
menschen wurden
da brauchen wir ein bisschen die panik
aus weil ich eben nicht wusste was genau
das war weil wir davon nichts
mitbekommen hatten und ich wollte
irgendwie einfach nur probieren schnell
weg und irgendwie meine familie
angerufen ob es einem gut geht und meine
freunde weil ich eben auch ein natürlich
nicht sicher sein konnte dass da jemand
dabei war der eben verletztes den ich
natürlich auch sehr gut kenne und ich
glaube es einfach so der geschockte
zustand ich habe angefangen zu zittern
aber trotzdem wirklich ich habe es nicht
realisiert und ist jetzt gerade auch
noch nicht ganz klar für mich dass das
eben so passiert ist nina war wie oft
erleben bei solchen taten dass sich die
berichterstattung und aber auch die
kommentare der user vor allem darauf
abzielen wer der täter war würde ich an
der stelle gerne versuchen weiter dabei
zu bleiben
wer die opfer waren und wie es den
menschen geht die das heute erlebt haben
auf youtube schreibt jopie disco oder zu
ziemlich menschlich das verhalten im
chat es wird halt nach einer erklärung
gesucht die sowas r greifbarer und
erträglicher macht das entschuldigt
manche kommentare aber nicht wir haben
noch einen zweiten beitrag von ellinor
die
wir an der stelle auch noch mal hören
können in der sie noch mal sehr
anschaulich beschreibt wie die situation
heute in trier war von augenzeugen haben
wir schon gehört dass sie berichtet
haben wie gegenstände durch die gegend
geflogen sind die menschen durch die
luft geflogen sind und eleanor schildert
das auch noch mal wir wollten eigentlich
nur ein geschäft rein und dann haben wir
dort ganz viele leute gesehen die total
aufgewühlt waren wir selber wussten halt
gar nicht was los war weil ich hab's ja
nicht live mitbekommen
ich habe nur irgendwie ganz viel sirenen
gehört und da stand dann auch schon
polizei und eben ein rettungswagen und
wir wussten gar nicht was los war und
wollten dann irgendwie nur schnell
zurück zur schule zumindest irgendwie
raus aus der stadt weil wir halt total
also wir haben uns schon jetzt in panik
bekommen und dann sind wir eben nicht im
hauptmarkt und dann war da auch das
erste kaputte schild und dann waren wir
irgendwie noch verwirrter weil wir dann
dachten okay da muss irgendwie ein auto
durch gefahren sein oder so und dann kam
es eben so dass wir bei tage gegangen
sind auf den hauptmarkt und dann war da
der erste verletzte und zwei mitarbeiter
lag schon wieder der nächste und so hat
das irgendwie über den ganzen hauptmarkt
gezogen
ja ganz also der langen dauer teilweise
schuhe die leute irgendwo anders
bestimmen drei feuerwehrfahrzeuge ganz
viele rettungsfahrzeuge waren da
die menschen sind alle total aufgewühlt
gewesen
ja ich glaube sehr viel ratlosigkeit
weil irgendwie keiner genau wusste was
das jetzt genau gewesen war
janina wie reagiert die stadt trier wie
reagieren die behörden auf diese
menschen die jetzt allen ansprechpartner
brauchen die jemanden brauchen der
zuhört der ihnen hilft in dieser
situation die angehörigen der verletzten
und schwerverletzten natürlich an erster
stelle aber auch viele viele die jetzt
einfach jemanden brauchen der sie hält
wie macht das trio heute abend wohin
gehen diese menschen ja also dazu kann
ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so
viel sagen hier ist jetzt tatsächlich
ich habe den eindruck die menschen sind
nach hause gegangen suchen trost bei
ihren nächsten es ist natürlich
gleichzeitig auch noch corona das heißt
hier draußen ist tatsächlich einfach
nichts mehr los bilder die wir sonst von
anderen orten kennen das auch mal leute
zusammenkommen und kerzen anzünden
blumen niederlegen das ist jetzt hier
aktuell noch nicht der fall das kann
natürlich noch passieren im moment wie
gesagt sind hier einfach wirklich sehr
sehr wenige menschen nur auf der straße
hinter mir ist jetzt gerade die polizei
noch dabei die die letzten sachen quasi
weg zu räumen und die steigen jetzt alle
so langsam in die autos und fahren wohl
auch also das ist hier gerade der stand
der dinge
kannst du aus deiner sicht als
reporterin noch einmal zusammenfassend
schildern was da an trier heute passiert
ist ja sehr gern also ich stehe hier
tatsächlich auch am tatort an der sieben
jahren straße das ist hier im herzen
trias die haupteinkaufsstraße direkt an
der porta nigra an dem wahrzeichen von
trier und da ist eben heute mittag ein
51 jähriger mann durch die
einkaufsstraße daran haben jetzt gehört
offensichtlich ins im zickzackkurs
entschuldigung jetzt hatte ich gerade
ein störgeräusch auf die auf dem ohr
kann dir vielleicht noch mal sagen ob
ihr mich hört und die frage noch mal
stellen
sorry ich glaube du hast einfach nur
mich gehört obwohl du mich gern ist gar
nicht hören soll mache einfach weiter
wir können dich sehr gut hören und wir
können dir auch gut folgen danke
hervorragend genau also wie gesagt der
traurige held tathergang heute mittag
ein 51-jähriger mann der hier durch die
haupteinkaufsstraße im herzen trias
gefahren ist offensichtlich und
zickzackkurs menschen angefahren hat
vier menschen wie wir wissen sind tot
darunter ein baby eine alte frau oder
ein alter mann wir wissen nur dass alter
ca 70 und eben auch viele verletzte
schwerverletzte die jetzt im krankenhaus
behandelt werden
tatort aus trier und bedanke mich bei
allen zuschauerinnen und zuschauern die
konstruktiv sich an diesem chat
beteiligt haben dankeschön fürs
zuschauen und ihnen allen einen schönen
abend
[Musik]